هذا الخراب هو ما خلفه قصف اوكراني على
مدينه دنياسك الخاضعه لسيطره روسيا بحسب
مسؤولين عينتهم موسكو القصف ياتي بعد يوم
من استبعاد روسيا وقف اطلاق النار بمناسبه
اعياد الميلاد رئيس بلديه المدينه المدعوم
من روسيا يقول ان رجيمات الصواريخ متعدده
من طراز بي ام 21 غراد اطلقت 40 صاروخا
على المدنيين في هجوم هو الاكبر الذي
تتعرض له دنياتك منذ عام 2014
بلديه مدينه خاركيف الاوكرانيه ان القوه
الروسيه هاجمه البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في
المدينه الواقعه اوكرانيا كما افادت هيئه
اركان العامه للجيش الاوكراني بان مسكت
يواصل قصف القوات الاوكرانيه والبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في منطقتي زبريتيا وخرسون
الجنوبيه من جهه اخرى ورد على التصريحات
التي تناقلتها وسائل اعلاميه حول اذيه
واشنطن لتزويد اكياس بمنظومه صواريخ
باتريوت حذرت الخارجيه الروسيه من خطوره
هذه الخطوه
بشده اولئك الذين يتخذون القرارات في
واشنطن ان يستمعوا ليس الينا وانما
لانفسهم وان يتوصلوا الى الاستنتاج الصحيح
من تحضيراتنا بان ايت انظمه اسلحه متوفرها
لاوكرانيا بما في ذلك باتريوت والعناصر
المشغله للانظمه ستكون على راس الاهداف
المشروعه للقوات الروسيه
قد قالوا لرويترز هذا الاسبوع من الاعلان
عن قرار بشان تزويد اوكرانيا بنظام
باتريوت قد يتم في وقت قريبا جدا وهي خطوه
من شانها ان تعزز الدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا
بشكل كبير فيما افادت صحيفه واشنطن باستا
بان الولايات المتحده تعتزم ايضا ارسال
معدات تحول الذخائر الجويه غير الموجهه
الى قنابل ذكيه مما يزيد من دقه الاستهداف